for people that struggle with weight
loss or chronic inflammation what is
something that they can add to their
diet that would help or is this simply a
game of stripping away you know even if
we look at something like obesity It's
always important to look at what is the
underlying Foundation of this outward
appearance or this outward manifestation
of a thing and inflammation can get drug
through the mud as this bad thing and we
want to stop all inflammation but
inflammation is critical for all
functions of life without inflammation
we wouldn't heal from an infection it
wouldn't heal from wounds we wouldn't
heal from a workout right it's a
critical part of our lives and of our
livelihood however when we dip into this
place of chronic inflammation acute
inflammation is one thing but it's kind
of like a low-grade fever and one of the
things that we know today is that when
our fat cells are overly full they start
to send out false distress signal
pulling in immune factors as if you're
infected and so researchers found out
how this is connected and essentially
one of the biggest issues with
inflammation is so we've got
inflammation in the body from the fat
cells distress signal and they found
that this inflammation in the brain was
creating more body fat and creating
higher levels of metabolic dysfunction
and that metabolic dysfunction and
higher levels of body fat is creating
more inflammation in the brain so what
do we do to help to bring a resolution
here because what happens is a vicious
circle obviously if neural inflammation
is creating more body fat and body fat
is creating more neural inflammation
we're getting trapped in this vicious
circle and most people are stuck in that
and their favorite Instagram account or
even their physician isn't telling them
we need to address this inflammation
specifically in your brain to help to
heal your body hey it's Evan Carmichael
and I make these videos because in my
first business I was making 300 bucks a
month I quit on my business partner and
the thing that saved me was studying the
stories of super successful
entrepreneurs so I hope that this story
today helps give you the motivation you
need because I still needed to myself so
today let's learn the super foods that
you need to eat to lose weight and
prevent disease enjoy
for researchers at Auburn univer
University found that there's this
particular food and I don't have a dog
in the fight I didn't I didn't care this
much about the fact by yeah and and you
know I was just blown away that this
actually had this action in the body and
what they found was that oleocanthal
rich extra virgin olive oil is able to
help to reduce neural inflammation
specifically helping to
heal the blood-brain barrier which is
has a tendency to get broken down by our
abnormal diet allowing more of these
kind of toxicants into the brain and
creating more inflammation do they know
the method of action
no we know so little still you know we
know a ton in nutrition right now but we
probably know maybe one percent of all
that there is to know right now yep it's
still so much more for us to discover
and so when folks are reaching out to
learn from folks you got to keep in mind
that even your favorite expert knows so
little and we can tend to put all of our
eggs in one basket in a sense with a
certain diet framework a belief about
diet
we might find out later on that olive
oil has some opposite effect but this is
what we know right now and I always like
to point people to leaning into
tradition humans have been utilizing
olive oil for thousands thousands upon
thousands of years
and it's very simply made because
there's also this movement today which
I'm grateful for towards addressing our
consumption of ultra processed foods
right now the average American
the average American's diet is 60 Ultra
processed foods right now whoa all right
I'm not surprised at all but still
hearing you say that is startling it's
crazy it's crazy but we have to be clear
grew up on Ultra I know you did me too
brother you know Ultra processed so I
look at my family morbidly obese
have been my entire life but many of
them have like managed to get into their
70s and I and I at the risk of
completely derailing where we were
headed I don't think people of our
generation are going to be able to look
the same as they looked and live as long
as they lived because my mom didn't get
into Ultra processed food let's say
until she was in her 20s whereas kids
now in the womb brother they're into
Ultra processed food and I think that
that 20 30 year span is going to be
devastating to People of Our Generation
like even I am so freaked out by the
fact that I know my mom was eating
terribly when she was pregnant with me
she smoked also while she was pregnant
that did not help and then uh my whole
life like I used to eat fried turkey
nuggets and french fries deep fried
turkey nuggets and french fries almost
every night you can't do that you can't
do that listen this is getting into the
fields of nutrigenomics and
nutrigenetics we have entire fields of
science looking at how each and every
bite of food that we eat impacts our
genetic expression and also how our
unique genetic makeup
leans towards certain nutrients certain
foods that work better for us versus
somebody else right now you're speaking
to this really important thing which is
what if we're doing this earlier because
there's so much of the body being made
foundational things like your brain
being made out of these compounds yep
right and so
but also mentioning you know your family
is very similar to mine very similar
this also speaks to something that we
look over which is the resilience of the
human body right you just said it we can
be in a state where we're probably
experiencing four different chronic
diseases and caring an insane amount of
excess body fat as well and still be
able to keep trucking along the body is
always trying to sort things out and to
fix things
if you think about something like type 2
diabetes which here in the United States
somewhere in the ballpark of about 130
million Americans have type 2 diabetes
or pre-diabetes right now a huge portion
of our population
now if you look at this condition so
we've got
dysfunction happening with our blood
sugar essentially we've got these beta
cells in our pancreas that are making
insulin right and insulin is getting
made and released in response to glucose
entering our bloodstream from the food
that we're eating primarily today we
have the ability to shuttle insane
amounts of food into our bloodstream at
one time that we never evolved with and
so insulin is going to be hyperactive
and at some point it's kind of like
it's kind of like a spam
a email scenario happening where you
keep getting this insulin message over
and over and over again until the inbox
the cell is just like I'm gonna block
you I'm gonna white I'm not gonna white
list this message and it's going to down
regulate its interaction with insulin
right so now we've got all of this
glucose running wild in the bloodstream
which
it's not exactly like this but a good
analogy is kind of like little shards of
glass right you can just tear stuff up
this is why we tend to have you know
when we're in this state of insulin
resistance and diabetes capillary issues
losing vision losing Limbs and things
that are further away from the core
right so where things are starting to
get a little bit more constricted start
to get torn up all right so
with that said
even though we're in the state the body
is making an adaptation
to that abnormal glucose to keep you
alive all right what insulin resistance
and diabetes is
it is
the body adapting to less than ideal
conditions or circumstances to keep this
person alive when exposed to all of this
blood sugar that could kill you all
right so there's this
intelligence and Grace that the body has
to keep operating and trucking us along
because what people tend to do on the
surface is like well you know we're
still living longer no right now this
generation is the first generation and
anybody can look this up that's not
going to outlive our predecessors that
process is reversed but also with our
Innovation you would think our lifespan
would continue regardless we're not
living longer we're dying longer we're
just extending the suffering with this
Ultra processed food awareness which I'm
grateful for we can get into a little
bit of
uh
teetering back and forth because
something like olive oil is a processed
food it's kind of heat it though
I'll answer that one second with with
olive oil right we've got a very simple
processing we take olives we crush the
olives with low temperature right that's
how it's traditionally done that is
processing
but it's it's minor processing versus
you taking uh
you know a couple of ears of corn and
turning it into Lucky Charms right right
like there's no connection whatsoever to
this thing and it's so riddled with
artificial colors and flavors and the
like how how high can you heat olive oil
to answer that question fantastic
question traditionally We're Not Really
Cooking with it as much by the way salad
dressings putting it on bread right
these are some of the ways that would be
used traditionally
if we are cooking with it we've got to
be mindful the reason it's in dark glass
is that it's heat and light sensitive
all right
it doesn't change it's because you pour
it into a pan
so just keep that in mind the common
moniker is happening to it when it's
getting heated up though is it is it
termination okay oh and also yeah it can
become rancid as well by not being
packaged correctly but olive oil is kind
of you know if you think about wines it
could stay like there was some research
that came out not too long ago that they
were finding old bottles of olive oil
like you know 100 years old or whatever
and cracking into it and it was fine I
wouldn't say it was fine personally you
know but it was edible and they didn't
die you know what I'm saying rule number
two is being mindful of what you eat
with Dr Steven gundry what are the main
plants that we should never be eating
then okay real quick uh up until 10 000
years ago we live primarily on the
leaves of trees and we ate two birds
that grew in the ground like a sweet
potato a yam love those yeah they're
actually they're pretty darn good for
you you know you were actually designed
to eat them and
12 000 years ago 10 000 years ago we
switched over to things that we had
never eaten before and those were the
grains of grasses and beans now the
reason we'd never eaten them before is
number one we didn't need to there's
never been a documentation of an ape
eating grass or grains beans are so
lethal that five raw kidney beans will
kill a human being in five minutes by
coagulating their blood what five raw
kidney beans raw kidney beans in fact
you know most people have heard of the
poison ricin the white powder you send
to your elected official oh yeah lots on
the way to Washington yeah that's
another subject so ricin is the lectin
of the castor bean and we'll talk about
lectins next
electin is the plant defense system
these are proteins that are designed to
basically kill us in one way or another
and so
ricin so powerful that about four
molecules of rice and will kill a human
being instantaneously
there's a great study that was written
up in one of the journals about a few
years ago they decided to have a healthy
eating day in Boston yeah and they serve
the kids beans and because it's so
healthy part of the Blue Zone yes and
they had
30 or 40 admissions to the hospital no
way with severe diarrhea hypotensions
and it turns out that it was all the
fact that the beans were undercooked
and beans are a plant baby and we're not
supposed to eat those and so no beans no
beans zero beans unless you use
pinto black none of that we shouldn't be
eating it shouldn't be you weren't
designed to eat it you had no defense no
matter how it's cooked if you pressure
pressure cook it it's fine pressure cook
it what does that even mean put it in a
pressure cooker the modern pressure
cooker is as easy as a rice cooker got
it it's one touch it's not your
grandmother's pressure cooker that blew
up in the kitchen so then it's okay to
eat yeah so you can pressure cook beans
now the other thing we weren't designed
to eat grains just a quick question
before you start there how much of it
can we eat doesn't matter once it's
pressure cooked obviously everything in
moderation but I mean yeah well like I
was presenting 20 beans are going to
kill me or whatever no if you pressure
cook them they're fine it's all good
okay and we talk about how to do this in
the plant Paradox but my personal
feeling is the only purpose of eating a
being is to get olive oil into my mouth
and we can talk about that as we go
along okay
so grains for instance everybody heard
about gluten yes all right so gluten is
a lectin and again a lectin is a plant's
defense system It's A protein that
actually is designed to act like
incoming guided missile attacks wow on
the inside wall of our gut and these
things actually pry open the lining of
our gut and actually break through the
Border really yeah they really do that's
what causes eczema and bingo breakouts
yeah exactly acne brain fog irritable
bowel this is actually all part of that
process and so it's fascinating to see
people who either have come to see me or
have even read the book and then write
on Amazon oh my gosh you know I had this
horrible eczema and now a month later
it's all gone and all I did was you know
take grains and beans and night shades
so away from my diet and everything got
better
so that brings us to the second kind of
group of things we should need
all of us are not from the United States
America we're actually from Europe Asia
or Africa and every one of us so and
even our Native Americans are actually
not Native Americans they're from Asia
you know get over it right that's right
so none of us were exposed to an
American Plant until 500 years ago when
Columbus started trade
so getting to know a new plant a new
lectin in 500 years is speed dating
in evolution and I just don't think it
would be done for instance the Italians
refused to eat tomatoes for 200 years
after their Native Son Columbus brought
them back because they knew how
dangerous they were they were part of
the deadly nightshade family
and they
when they started eating them they
always peeled and deseeded their
tomatoes because the Peels and the seeds
actually have the vast majority of the
lectins and it's interesting years ago I
was uh did my fellowship in children's
heart surgery in London England and I
had a house officer from Italy and he
invited me up for pasta and tomato sauce
yes so I I brought you know it'd be nice
if I bought a couple cans of canned
tomatoes you know help out sure and he
looks at he says why did you bring me
this we can't use this right what do you
mean you have canned tomatoes he says
it's got Peels and seeds you can't make
sauce with Peels and seeds he says
what am I going to do with you you can't
use Peels and seeds I said why he says
they're deadly and I said really and he
says yeah everybody knows that and then
I thought back as a child my mother my
grandmother was French and she taught my
mother that you always peel and deseed
tomatoes before you slice them and and
serve them so until I went to Yale I had
never had a slice of a tomato with a
peel and a seat wow and
we it this was you know this has come
from cultures rule number three is pay
attention to how you feel with Mark
Hyman if you were to put together a few
groups of
um
the sort of healing signals what would
they be like what would be if if you
were so
um in investing there's this thing
called the all-weather strategy and they
say okay look uh I'm sort of blindly
talking to my grandchildren I'm you know
gonna pass away and all I can leave
behind is a strategy that will work in
in any environment but if you had to
just put together an all-weather eating
strategy what would the ideal in air
quotes I wrote about it I wrote a whole
book about it it's called food what the
heck should I eat and it's about these
principles like home the pig and
principles and it's really focused on
quality first right nobody thinks we
should be adding additives and hormones
and abiotics and pesticides and
glyphosate to our food like it's in it
but nobody's like yeah we avoid it at
the grocery store uh you know if you
look at the label of something if it has
something you can't recognize pronounce
uh then you shouldn't have it or if you
don't have it in your cupboard at home
like mutilated hydroxytoluene which is
in almost every processed food is BHT
it's illegal in Europe you wouldn't
sprinkle that on your salad would you
but no so that's a good rule uh the
second principle is you know we should
be eating a plant-rich diet uh and and
across the Spectrum from
fruits and vegetables to do you treat
fruits and vegetables as sort of one and
the same or No it should be vegetables
and fruit right so it's like we should
you don't want to be consuming only
fruit because that's full of sugar and
and if you're diabetic or you're
overweight or have issues you might want
to cut back on the sugary fruits or eat
berries which are less glycemic
lots of nuts and seeds everybody agrees
with being lost in this and seeds you
want to soak them or do selectins that's
fine if you're going to eat beans and
Grains pick low starch ones right and
and also give us a few examples so like
black rice which is like the blueberries
of rice quinoa what does that mean well
the black rice is called the emperor's
rice or forbidden rice and it's full of
these dark it's black so anytime you see
color in nature there are polyphenols
and phytochemicals in there so it's got
more antioxidants per serving than
blueberries and then and then you want
to make sure
if you're eating you know grains the
gluten grains are are interesting so
most of the gluten we eat is is wheat uh
it's 133 pounds per person per year
that's a pharmacologic dose it is worse
for your blood sugar than table sugar
really yes what yes when you look at the
glycemic index which is how much the
fixed amount of the food will raise your
blood sugar table sugar is 80 red is a
hundred
whoa I had no idea why because it's so
processed and so quickly absorbed and if
you want to eat like if you're not
gluten says you want to have Pharaoh or
iron corn wheat or you know spell you
might tolerate those because those are a
highly altered genetically but the new
the wheat we eat is super starchy has a
lot more gliding proteins create more
gluten sensitivity is spray with
glyphosate at Harvest to defoliate the
plants and this also has preservative
called calcium propionate which cause
autism in animal models and is shown to
cause behavioral problems in kids so add
all that stuff could be all the flour so
I'm not a big flower person plus it's
just like sugar so if you want to have
other grains if you're not going to say
like Rye or barley that's fine
and then beans again you know lime beans
kidney beans if you're if like 75 of
Americans overweight so most people
should be eating a lot of starch and
that you know you have to eat three cups
of beans to get the equivalent of like
four or six ounces of protein uh so I
have this lentils and things like that
um which are lower starch beans the Zuki
beans other kinds of beans I talk about
in my book and then if you're eating
animal products you want any animal
products that are not
going to hurt the animals not going to
hurt you and not going to hurt the
environment right so for beef it should
be regeneratively raised ideally which
is hard to find but you can actually get
more and more of that around and there's
ways to do it by by looking online to
get it looking Thrive Market is a great
resource for a regenerally raised beef
and again chicken should be pasture
raised pork and all that should be
raised in ways that are are more organic
or sustainable fish you want to eat fish
that's sustainably harvested or you know
sustainably organically aquacultured
because we over harvest the fish and
then we don't eat big fish it's like
full of mercury and tuna and swordfish
because they've lived longer well what
happens is the coal and all the fossil
fuels go in the ocean going to algae get
stored in the algae that the little fish
eat the algae then the little bigger
fish eat the little fish and it goes on
up the food chain and you got a
swordfish or a tuna these are monster
fish and they bioaccumulated all this
and so you want to you know eat the
right animal products you want to eat
the right grains the right beans the
right vegetables the right fruits and so
right nuts give me the right vegetables
are we just looking for color so
non-starchy vegetables if you want to
cut out nightshades and go to the
lectins that's fine you know I don't
care but I love tomatoes and it'll make
me feel bad uh so there's no point in
restricting your diet necessarily if
you're not sick right talking really
fast just because you mentioned that you
eat night shades which are problematic
for a lot of people I've heard you say
that your body is the best doctor yeah
exactly so I mean you listen and watch
my stuff that's some brown impressed so
the the whole idea is that
you can listen to all the nutritional
advice you want but pay attention to how
you feel your body is going to tell you
if you go vegan
and you stop having your period you lose
muscle you feel tired you're B12
deficient you feel like crap eat about
autoimmune diseases you gain weight
whatever maybe it's not for you right I
mean I literally just did a whole
analysis on a very well-known celebrity
and he's a vegan and he's massively
nutritional efficient no omega-3s
extremely low vitamin D extremely low B
vitamins extremely low zinc selenium I
mean it was frightening to see in a
young guy how depleted he was but other
people that works really well for him
and then see how you feel if you get rid
of gluten and dairy do you feel better
right so I had people do a detox but
essentially a dietary cleanse which is
get off all the junk get off all the
sugar get off all the processed food eat
Whole Foods get rid of gluten and dairy
even get rid of grains and beans for a
while and see how you feel and if you
don't feel good you know try to add
things back if you feel amazing and your
autoimmune disease goes away your
digestive problems clear up your brain
fog's clear your migraines are gone
well then that's probably a sign that
your body likes that wave you know also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is cut sugar with
Mark Sison when I started researching
the Primal endurance book I started
thinking well you know all of the
science continues to show us that the
old Choice was probably a wrong choice
that Reliance on carbohydrate rates and
that that intent of of managing our
glycogen stores and our muscles was kind
of the wrong approach and maybe we ought
to come at it from the exact opposite
end of the Spectrum which is how do we
become really good at burning fat and in
so doing spare glycogen and in so doing
uh unburden ourselves of having to take
in so much carbohydrate in the form of
pasta and Breads and cereals and rice
and crackers and cookies and all the
other stuff sure and you're you're 62
right yeah right and you're like leaner
than anyone I know so how what's the
most effective way to burn fat and still
be strong yeah of course you know as we
said initially in the Primal blueprint
and I've said it decades before the I
wrote The Blueprint eighty percent of
your body composition is determined by
how you eat so if you there's a certain
way in which you can eat where you can
literally reprogram your genes to derive
most of your energy from your stored
body fat really yes so as opposed to
waking up being hungry having breakfast
being hungry at the 10 30 break being
hungry for lunch having a snack in the
afternoon having a dinner and having a
snack before you go to bed which is the
sort of standard American approach like
even the old bodybuilders would say
don't go more than three hours without
eating or you will cannibalize your
muscle tissue right that was all based
on an assumption that we had to burn
carbohydrate had to had to access
glucose and glycogen for the muscles to
be able to to continue to work it never
contemplated that we are obligate fat
burners we are born with this amazing
ability to extract calories from stored
body fat and the and the reason that we
don't as we go through life is we
present our you know you're two years
old you're eating cookies and crackers
and mushed peas
all that stuff and so your body learns
to depend on on glucose on carbohydrates
as a source of energy it never really
gets to the point where you force it to
burn fat so what we do is we we shift
the diet around
it's not painful you get rid of the
breads the pastas the cereals the
crackers the cookies the candies the
sweet and soft drinks well it does sound
kind of nice doesn't it but but what
you're left with is meat fish foul eggs
nut seeds vegetables a little bit of
fruit some starchy tubers like sweet
potatoes things like that those are
great tasting Foods if you get them
right and they're real food and they're
real food and you can use butter and
lard and and you can eat bacon on this
on this program and what it does is it
reduces the amount of simple sugars and
carbohydrates you take in and just sort
of forces gently forces your body to to
upregulate all the enzyme systems that
access stored body fat and burn it and
allow you to have more energy throughout
the day without having to eat so often
so the first thing that happens is your
appetite self-regulates so now you you
you get into the space where you become
a good fat burner you start to melt away
your ass hungry because you're not and
you're not as hungry because you're
always carrying around a meal it's on
your thighs it's on your ass it's on
your belly wherever it is it's you know
that's your body becomes so Adept at
accessing those stored calories it says
I don't need to eat I'm really not that
hungry wow yeah and that's so empowering
for so many people when you you know I
was uh still love sugar but I used to be
really bad at Sugar I feel like I have
much more under control but I feel like
when you're eating a lot of candy sweets
and sugar you're never satisfied you
just want to eat more and more and more
but that's until you're sick no exactly
yeah I'm full because I'm sick now yeah
I mean stories of Lamar Odom eating four
pounds of candy four games or whatever
yeah but I mean we are look we're all
hired look where he's at now you know
it's like we're all but sort of by the
way sugar is a very addictive substance
so addictive so
um you know we're all hardwired to seek
out sweet things that's part of that
hunter-gatherer DNA that we all carry
really hasn't changed in in thousands of
years
shift our mind so you the first way you
do it is is you go from from the craving
which is what you're talking about like
you crave sugar so you eat sugar and
then that just promotes more craving and
it gets you into this sort of addictive
cycle you're actually producing sort of
opiate like substances that are that are
occupying receptor sites that are giving
you sort of a feel-good experience so
you got to kind of be willing to to get
rid of that so you get rid of the
candies you get rid of the sweetened
beverages the soft drinks of Teas and
you get rid of the carbohydrates that
not all carbs but the the breads that
convert to glucose in the bloodstream so
rapidly
so now you've lowered your blood your
glucose experience on a daily basis so
now the brain is starting to get you
know I don't need to really get that
much glucose you know I can I can the
body is burning more fat as a result of
your being able to burn fat you you
should create these byproducts called
ketones which the brain loves to burn
ketones and burns them preferentially so
you you need less and less sugar to you
know maintain Clarity throughout the day
if you're if you haven't become fat
adapted and you're a sugar burner which
is what we it's not a derogatory term
but we usually we use the term to
describe people who haven't become fat
burners yet they're sugar burners if you
don't eat it's true if you don't eat for
a couple of hours your blood sugar dips
because you haven't learned how to burn
fat yet you don't know how to access it
you can't take it out of storage and
burn it so now the blood sugar is low
the brain goes I gotta go get some more
glucose I gotta get energy so much sugar
or something sugar until you have the
bagel at you know at 10 30 in the
morning or you have tastes amazing well
for an hour and then it's no exactly but
then you're hungry again and that's uh
and that's this vicious cycle so if we
can you know take the steps we say it
takes 21 days that's why I have a book
called the 21 day total body
transformation 21 days of this uh
cutting these these sugars and and
starchy um not starchy but uh simple
carbohydrates uh out of your diet and
just focusing on healthy fats and lean
proteins and and uh uh you know and
vegetables right uh you get you your
body gets the message and says I'm not
going to be getting that much glucose
I'm going to learn how to burn fat and
I'm going to do it well damn it and and
then it takes the fat out of your body
fat stores so over time you lose a pound
two pounds a week a new trend toward
your ideal body composition wow so all
of this is a 10 minute long-winded uh
answer to your uh question of how you
know what does it take to you know to
burn fat it doesn't take a lot of
exercise it mostly takes the dietary
shift right yeah you got to do some
exercise you don't have to do anything
but you can choose to do some exercise
it'll help accelerate and it'll help
accelerate it a little bit but most of
it happens as a result it really shifts
you making your diet absolutely it's all
in the kitchen yep rule number five is
do intermittent fasting with Dr Daniel
Eamon how much food should the brain
have is it you know it's your buddy our
buddy uh Dave asprey talks about fasting
a lot a lot of people are in this
fasting craze if we're not giving the
brain food or nutrients for a day three
days five days is that help the brain
does it reset the brain does it hurt the
brain so intermittent fasting where you
go 12 to 16 hours from dinner to
breakfast or lunch is good they've
actually found your there's a term
called autophagy where your brain begins
to clean up some of the trash so it
works in the brain too not just in the
it works on the brain as as well now I
grew up Roman Catholic and long
suffering was one of the gifts and I
never got that one I'm not a fan of long
suffering yes I'm not doing a marathon
it's like way too much stress for my
brain and I'm not fasting for three days
but I can go 12 hours and I'm like
that's not a big deal and it helps
people lose weight it helps them be
healthy and I come from a family of fat
people my dad used to say when I would
say that but I have a brother that's 150
pounds overweight despite me loving him
nudging him and
you just have to be thoughtful know your
vulnerability and bright Minds that g is
genetics so know what you're genetically
vulnerable to and you know I have to
work on it rule number six eat omega-3
rich foods with William Lee all the
research scientific research has been
done and the epidemiological the public
health research shows that eating a
plant-based mostly plant-based diet that
that's pretty broad you know um uh
fruits vegetables legumes nuts healthy
oils good for you you should eat most of
mostly that
doesn't mean and by the way plant-based
could be tricky because a lot of ultra
processed foods also have plant
materials in it process soy all kinds of
other things all kinds of unhealthy oils
made from Plants however if it's whole
plant-based Foods
it's kind of stuff you'd find a grocery
store or a farmer's market okay like I
would say mostly go for those mostly go
for those okay
um uh Seafood has been shown to improve
survival and decrease the risk of death
if you eat two or three servings of of
seafood shelf it could be fish or
shellfish you get a healthy omega-3
fatty acids per day per week two to
three servings per week and the amount
you would eat uh which I write a whole
chapter about food doses amount you
would eat is about three ounces so
people like well wait I'm not a human
scale I have no idea what three ounces
is what I would say it's a lot less than
you think it is a piece of fish about
the size of a deck of playing cards you
can put it in your palm it's about yay
it's about as thick as a thick of
playing cards not that big a deal and
you know um and and people who love
seafood can can get a lot of it that way
recently there was an interesting study
that showed if you actually increase
your level of Omega-3s by an extra
serving a week or two like from wherever
you are with your starting point you can
increase your longevity your Survival by
4.7 years
so an extra serving of of
Omega-3 Rich Seafood you increase your
Survival by LifeTime Survival by 4.7
years now you can get if you're a vegan
or a vegetarian you can get Omega-3s
from plant-based Foods so chia seeds
flax seeds some of the nuts you can get
those as well but what in plant-based
Foods you get a different kind of
substrate to make your Omega-3s so you
got to eat a lot more of it so you know
um I I I like diversity and rule number
seven the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is eat close to the
ground with Dr Jeffrey Bland I love the
idea of personalization I think that's
really important that was something that
we learned with Lisa as she was going
through everything was just like things
they don't bother me but they'll bother
her and they'll bother her really
substantially and things that make me
put on fat don't make her put on fat and
so it's like this really weird thing of
um you really do have to personalize it
I heard you say that this is going to be
the age where we go from the age of the
average to the age of the individual
right I thought that's really important
uh you talked about the future of
medicine being the ability to
um look at the intersection of genetics
and the lifestyle and then you you
didn't say AI but that was certainly
what I took away from it that we're
gonna use AI effectively to really look
at what is the interaction they're in
and being able to carry our own medical
records with us decipher all of that
now having said all of that and we're
going to go into this time where we're
going to be able to do a lot more than
we can do now
but what are like the the basics that
you advise for people
is it eat the rainbow is it don't need
sugar is it plants only no what's not
plants only I I think eating close to
the ground as much as possible in the
ground does that mean it means things
that we're alive got it that didn't get
through seven processes of uh of
processing to be shelf stable for
Millennia
um and and we're going now into an epic
period as you probably know there's this
uh uh this recent book about Silicon
Valley now taking over the food supply
system through this new food technology
doing fermentation technology to produce
uh mimics the to animal protein and
synthetic milk proteins that come from
clone genes from unicellular organisms
this is a real Trend you know we see it
with the impossible burgers and these
meat substitutes so the question is are
they the same and
the answer is they may taste the same
they may even look the same they cook
the same but they're not the same I mean
nature is complex and the more we study
foods that we're growing in soils or
foods that were eaten by animals that
were grown in soils the more we find out
that there are things we didn't ever
even know about that are part of this
orchestration so my feeling is eat the
rainbow but it's not the synthetic
rainbow it's it's foods that have their
natural colorants because each of those
colors is a different phytochemical that
has a different principle now let me say
something quickly about that because
this Loops back to your really I think
insightful question about phytochemicals
we used to think about phytochemicals as
being antioxidants and and so it's just
like measuring the phytochemical content
in your diet was to use an indication
that's on food some food labels called
orac orac which stands for oxygen
reducing capacity oxygen reducing
absorbent capacity orac and so it was
said well the higher the orac value the
the better that food is because it has
more antioxidant potential
well I'm kind of a early stage
antioxidant researcher going back into
the 70s so I think I have some pedigree
in this area and I've been saying for
more than 20 years it's not about
antioxidants alone that makes these
plant Foods valuable so you just can't
substitute one orac for another orac and
get the same thing because each of those
chemicals that are in those individual
plants those phytochemicals has unique
signaling properties I'm going back to
your original Concepts that they send a
signal to the genes that's used unique
to them so a glucosinolite phytochemical
coming from cruciferous vegetables is
different than the polyphenols of
Atlantic acid coming from berries they
both are antioxidants but they have
entirely different physiological
mechanisms and therefore what are we
really trying to accomplish are we
trying to rejuvenate the immune system
through the hormetic effects of multiple
signals on goal so that we have an
offense not just a defense that's
producing a younger immune system I I
went on our own program our immuno
Rejuvenation program him and I consider
myself a pretty dedicated
healthy person exercise proper sleep
blah blah blah so I went on our program
and I started measuring my epigenetic
programming of my immune system when I
started off at the age of 75 I guess is
when I started this my immune system Age
based upon epigenetic profiling using AI
determination of the methylation
patterns of my immune cells was I was I
was 75 in birthdays but I was 67 in my
immunity so he said well that's that's
pretty good I'm I'm my immune system is
younger than my age and birth things but
then I really dedicated myself to our
program and I really said could I really
have an effect that would be beyond that
of what I've seen and lo and behold
another three months in retesting I was
53. whoa yeah I I dropped it another
seven years what'd you do I went on to
our immuno Rejuvenation program exactly
what you and I are talking about I
religiously dedicated myself to stay on
the program actually exercise sleep
Stress Management polyphenols
omega-3 fatty acids prebiotics
probiotics the whole nature of what
we're trying to do in big bold Health
was whole food or supplementation it
makes whole food with some
supplementation because I can't in the
way I live my life always every meal
prepare it from the way that I would
want it to be prepared so you know we
try to provide some convenience in the
way that can be done but it starts
obviously with food
you mentioned that you can do 14
different activities at a given moment
so we all are very curious to know how
can we achieve such progress over both
body and mind
oh
it was said this I didn't say anything
like that anyway
do you have a liver
functioning
yes
do you know how many levels of activity
it's doing right now
what the liver is doing is far more
complex than what your brains are doing
right now do you know this
a brainless liver if it can do so many
things
how many things
no I was only talking about
not activity per se
yes activity is also possible
so you must understand this
on a round Planet which is spinning
right now
hello
are you on a round planet
spinning
most people don't understand this
unless you know they get suzzled out
with something
or they get some ailment suddenly you
see planet is round
do you know how complex an activity it
is
for a human being to work at a certain
latitude on a round Planet which is
spinning and which has magnetic forces
working upon you all the time
it's an extremely complex process
you ask a child
who is let's say one year of age she
knows how complex it is
have you seen
but the moment you learn to walk
you assume that it's nothing walking is
nothing and you're sick of walking you
want to drive a car you want to ride a
motorcycle
but walking is such a complex process
not 14.
a thousand different functions your
knees and your brains and the fluids in
your body all of them are doing all the
time
if only you could conduct these things
consciously you would be doing a
thousand things any way you're doing it
but if you could conduct this
consciously you do a thousand things at
a time so I was only talking about
different channels of mind
which you don't have to actually conduct
you just have to initiate and leave
it will go on
for you to think about your neighborhood
girl do you have to initiate action
every time
no
once you look at her it just goes on by
itself why because you're drawn to it
if you are drawn to 10 different things
at the same time
mind is capable of creating 10 different
channels and keep it running
a complex mathematical problem a
sensation a music some Raga this that
hundred things at the same time because
that is how complex human mind is this
complexity you can use either to drive
yourself crazy with unbridled thought
and emotion or if you harness it it can
do things that nobody has imagined
possible
it can do things
in a miraculous way you can manifest
things in a phenomenal way if the
necessary training goes if somebody is
walking there if you just look at them
how they are walking you can make out
whether they're physically fit or not
yes or no body has been worked upon you
can see it or no just by the walk
similarly whether the mind has been
worked upon or not whether your energies
have been worked upon or not
is something that's visible most people
may not see but if you pay attention you
will see right now most human beings the
problem is we gave you a super super
computer
the most sophisticated machine on this
planet is this human mechanism I am
asking you have you read the user's
manual
hello
no
when you're going to read it on the last
day
when I see these ridiculous stuff people
reading Gita when people are dying I say
you're reading the user's manual on the
last day what's the point
laughs
if you buy a phone should you read the
user's manual in the first three days or
after three years when you want to get
rid of the phone
huh you must read it in the first three
days
so I am not asking you to read a
scripture
well this is a living scripture should
you not become competent to read the
scripture understand what is the nature
of this what is the full potential of it
and explore this because this life is
not about this or that this life is
about this
there is no choice about this
it is just that you can enslave this
life to something else and think it's
about that
but actually it's about this are you
okay with this
you think right now your life is about
education no your life is about this
you want this one educated you want this
one to do well you want this one to
experience love you want this one to
experience pleasure you want this one to
do all this
all the other things are only
attendant things this is the real thing
isn't it
so if this is the real thing he does
this deserve some amount of attention
some amount of attention means not
standing in front of the mirror and
attending to your skin endlessly
should you not pay attention to every
dimension of what this human being is
made of
what makes this life tick
and how if you understand what makes it
tick you can make it roll
if you make a drawer why 14 things you
can do many more there's four or five
single actions you could take
to actually
impact your own
um your own
um Health and Longevity and and show
that you've done it
who's the stem cell guy
so his name is Dr Todd ovakitis
and he has invented
um
some things that is like so
mind-boggling uh that I actually David
Sinclair who's kind of the leader in the
field I was talking to David I
introduced him to Todd he went to Todd
and he's like Todd you're going to win a
Nobel Prize for this
so basically so stay with me now because
this is a little bit all right we're
diving in this is it all right so stem
cells are a really big deal
um and they they
um
are designed to fix things
that's why they exist and to also lower
inflammation in the body which is great
um
and when before we're born and up to the
time we're born we have a massive number
of stem cells called embryonic stem
cells and they're doing they're like the
worker bees that are building everything
and they're they're they and they can
create and build and fix anything we
lose those the day we're born
um but we still have a ton of stem cells
in our body and they can be extracted
previously in one of two ways either
through body fat which you look like you
have extremely little or
um through bone marrow
ouch
but he and he has invented a way to
extract it from blood
and not only has he figured out how to
extract it from blood
but
they are the closest stem cells to the
embryonic stem cell they're the most
potent they can change in in in into
anything in in theory fix anything
whereas the the
stem cells from muscle sorry from fat or
from bone marrow they they're Limited in
what they can do and what they can fix
um so
what he does is he extracts blood from
you
um a few tubes
does his magic on them spins them and
whatever else
and then he re-injects it into your body
and here's the magic part he uses a
patented laser to actually direct the
stem cells
where they're needed the most
so let's say just for example that your
mom has kidney problems you know her
kidneys aren't functioning at 100
percent
well he would aim the lasers at her
kidneys so that all those beautiful
embryonic like stem cells would assemble
themselves at the kidneys and work to
start fixing the kidney right if you
didn't have that the stem cells would go
wherever they feel like going oh maybe
your mom's got an infection in her big
toe well they all decide to go to her
big toe right so you can't direct stem
cells unless you have a method of doing
it and he's invented a method of doing
that
um and so he's moved my age back three
or four years so far
um and he's also cured a
a
inherited thing I've got actually on my
hand that um is incurable it's not a bad
thing it'll never kill you but it's it's
um it's a genetic
call it a malformation and after he
applied the laser to my hand
um I started seeing the these little
calluses to start to disappear and I
showed it to my doctor and he said you
realize that can't happen this this goes
One Direction the wrong direction and
there's nothing that can stop it and I'm
like well guess what
so there's there is some magical magical
things going on out there I would rather
you
take uh
uh you know you're become you become the
world's expert on and you're like a
complete genius
in your area
the question is are you willing to take
the time to become an expert or at least
bring in a team of experts on this
for you for your parents for your wife
for your kids
it's a really really really big deal but
it's all below the water surface now and
if you're not willing it's like the
early days of anything you know you got
to be willing to learn about it assemble
it yourself play around with it know
who's in the know that's the stage we're
at right now the secret to being healthy
is being happy the secret to being
healthy is being happy the more stressed
out you are the more you feel like
you're living out of alignment with your
goals and dreams the more you feel like
you're not making any kind of progress
in your business or your career the more
you feel like the work you do doesn't
matter and your relationships don't
matter that's going to lead you down a
path of anxiety depression illness
sickness disease suicide it's a it's a
really dangerous slippery slope but the
more you feel happy that today matters
that good things are going to happen to
you guess what they're more likely to
actually happen people ask me all the
time Evan how are you so positive all
the time well I'm not positive all the
time I mean that's an impossibly high
standard but I try not to be negative
that much and when negative things
happen to me I try not them I try not to
let them ruin my entire day let alone my
entire week or my entire month right
people lost her are shocked when they
find out that I'm 41 years old they ask
me how old am I am 41. born in 1980 like
what how are you 41 you look a lot
younger like well thank you but I think
a lot of it has to do with happiness
like when you love the thing that you're
actually doing when you're excited when
you have energy it it exudes through you
and has the impact on other people as
well I've been asked on a bunch of
Health shows what's your number one
secret for good health and
people expect to hear diet or exercise
or sleep I think the number one secret
for good health
is being happy
is loving the work that you're doing is
feeling like you're doing something
important and so maybe that's backed up
by the science by now but it feels
intuitively right to me and let me share
with you a couple ways how to do it okay
well that's great Evan be happy
well how do we actually do it so let me
share some things that have worked in my
life that I that hope can have an impact
on yours as well so number one is try to
run a no crisis life a no crisis
business and a no crisis life one of the
things that I stressed out over a lot
when I first started my company was
always being at the beck and call of
other people I used to pride myself on
responding to emails really quickly I
used to use Outlook back in the day and
anytime an email came in there was a
little alert that came off alert new
email like oh and so I had to stop what
I was doing and then go respond to this
email
and that that cycle would reinforce
itself because anytime somebody then
responded they say wow you're so fast on
answering email
and that would make me want to answer it
even faster the next time what I ended
up finding out though was I kept
dealing with other people's emergencies
other people's requests for my time
other people's agenda for what they
wanted me to do and I dealt with all
those things and I never got the stuff I
wanted to do it never got done because I
kept being distracted to go answer these
emails or respond to that message
and so I had to make a conscious choice
to say I want to run a no crisis
business
and if a client needs me for something
that is urgent I don't want that kind of
client if we need to respond to customer
service which I believe is really
important I'm going to hire people to
help me do that but I I don't want to be
in the business where I have to be on
call
urgent responding to people because it
stresses me out and I don't want to be
in that business so how can you design a
no crisis business same thing for uh
your life you know for me
I love living in this condo uh a lot of
the stuff is taken care of you know we
don't have roof issues or having to mow
the lawn or things that break down and
having to call somebody and because the
air conditioner is broken or the toilet
doesn't work or oh I mean all the stuff
I built a 5 000 square foot custom home
and sold it to move into the condo
because it's it's a much lower crisis
life and when you don't have a lot of
crisis in your life and in your business
holy cow you can be a lot happier and
that positivity allows you to be more
creative to be more productive to care
more but others to give more into others
when you're stressed out not only is it
bad for your health you're not showing
up for other people right you're not
being caring for other people you're not
thinking of other people you're not
invested into your customers or your
relationships or your team because
you're still too stressed out dealing
with your own issues but when you can
relieve some of those things it allows
you to pour into other people just a a
quick example from my life the past
three weeks have been actually pretty
stressful
um we have been looking at different
real estate options we have been looking
at different Financial options I'm I'm
diving deep into uh buy borrow die if
you look at that up as a financial
strategy I've been learning about crypto
I've been learning about nfts I've been
learning about infinite banking
pause good afternoon this is your
building superintendent thank you for
your patience
monthly generator test
all elevators in both towers are fully
operational enjoy the rest of your day
so that's a great example right like
sure that's a minor Interruption to me
filming videos for you guys but a lot of
stuff is just taken care of so the past
two weeks have been have been
more stressful and have led to things
bleeding into my calendar I've let them
happen I didn't put enough guard rails
around my calendar think of blood into
my calendar and I'm doing things on days
that I normally aren't doing things and
it's led to me feeling more anxiety and
stress and so over the weekend this past
weekend I decided you know what I'm
doing things on the day that I said I
was going to do things on and that's it
and it means say no to people and as a
result
uh I'm filming this on a Tuesday since
then it was Sunday it's like oh
life feels good again
feels really good again why I'm so happy
again there's so much more energy again
because I feel like I'm back in control
and so setting up a no crisis business
no crisis life
can free up just so much energy for you
and will make you a lot happier step
number two to make that happen is be in
control of your calendar
you have goals you have Ambitions of
what a dream life looks like for you
right perfect your actions need to map
to your ambitions so what's in your
calendar should reflect your goals you
say you want to be here you say you want
this kind of uh marriage this kind of
body this kind of business this kind of
financial success whatever your goals
are great until their habits until
you're doing the work nothing's gonna
happen you're never going to achieve
that thing without it being a habit that
you're doing consistently so where are
your habits tracked in your calendar
show me your calendar and you'll be able
to see your outcomes
so you have to be protective over your
calendar and the stress that I had over
the past couple weeks was because I let
things run over my calendar too much and
I had to take back control when somebody
wanted to meet with me because I became
obsessed about something one of the
things I fight with as I get obsessed
over things and so I became obsessed
with under understanding nfts and
Discord and buy borrow die and all sorts
of these Concepts and so I want to meet
with somebody and I want to learn it and
so yes okay yeah I could squeeze that in
there or I can squeeze this in here and
then I wasn't getting the other stuff
done that I was supposed to do on those
days so let the stress
so same thing for you what are your
goals what do you want to accomplish you
have enough time when people say I don't
have enough time
audit your schedule
like if you were gonna sit next to you
and watch what you're doing all day is
every hour that you're spending really
productive is every hour you're spending
really intentional probably not
right so before you decide to do
something like give up on sleep people
ask me how much do you sleep I sleep as
long as I need to sleep I don't set an
alarm in the morning and I sleep as long
as my body tells me to sleep
I think before worrying about giving up
sleep you don't have to only sleep five
hours a night you know I'll sleep seven
and a half to eight and a half hours a
night
right some some days more some days less
but that's my typical range that's what
my body needs depending on how busy a
day I had the night before
you worry about giving up an hour of
sleep audit how you're doing with the
time that you're awake you know if
you're gonna sleep eight hours perfect
you're awake for 16 hours or 16 of your
hours with intention with efficiency
with with Clarity of how you're going to
spend that time probably not right so
before you worry about now you're you're
not being productive or intentional with
your 16 hours what makes you think that
now you're going to be productive and
intentional with 20 hours
yeah and now you've slept four Less
hours
right so Focus instead on the hours that
you are awake and put in your calendar
your goals have to map to the actions
that you've got right you say you want
this show it to me in your calendar and
then put guard rails up around those
things it really really matters when you
can do that it takes a few hard no's
because people will want you to do
things and they'll want you to do things
on their timelines and that may mean you
have to say no you will have to say no
you'll have to say no to family you have
to say no customers you have to stay
another team
but when you can set up the right time
to make things happen it makes things so
much happier and easier for everybody so
as an example I film my videos on a
Tuesday today's a Tuesday I don't know
when the video is going to be released
but I film it on a Tuesday so I can stay
in the zone of just creating all I have
to worry about today is making lots of
YouTube videos yesterday was Monday and
I'm I'm only focused on my team
and so my team knows that hey if they're
messaging me on a Tuesday it better be
urgent like it better be crazy urgent
and I run a no crisis business so it
better be something insane otherwise
don't message me on a Tuesday right
because it's going to interrupt my flow
it means I have to stop doing this video
to see what message you sent and so that
better be really really really really
important and that very rarely comes up
it's not that it's actually no crisis
we'll have something every now and then
that comes up
but they know that it it better be just
insanely important so it very rarely
happens
so I'm not there for my team on a
Tuesday right I'm not there for my team
on a filming day like this but I'm all
in on Mondays
I'm all in helping my team on Mondays
and so what I do is I ask them hey if
you need me within 24 hours email me
if you need me within a week then let's
discuss it on our Monday call we're
going to meet you on Monday let's
discuss it on Monday save up the things
that are important and save it for
Monday for our call I will be there not
distracted not checking my phone not
thinking YouTube not thinking about
anything else except you on Monday and
what that does is allow you to really
over deliver on the thing that you're
doing as opposed to being scatterbrained
all over the place
so Chunk in your time and then setting
up the guard rails around that so that
people don't step all over it is really
really really important and when you can
feel like there's always a spot on your
calendar to get that thing done
it reduces stress dramatically
so if I'm worried about my YouTube
channel like oh my gosh you got to make
videos when are we gonna make videos
when you don't have it in your calendar
and when you don't feel like you have
enough time how much of your stress
comes from you feeling like you don't
have enough time to do something
right
raise your hand is that you
how much of your stress comes from you
feeling like you do not have enough time
if you had a spot on your calendar where
you knew you would have the time to do
it it reduces a lot of the stress so for
me Tuesday is going to be YouTube day if
I get an idea for making videos if I'm
thinking about making content I know oh
I've got Tuesday to do it I'll send
myself an email
and on Tuesday I'll get to it
when's is my project day so when I have
ideas for what I want to do in my
business to grow at other projects to
work on if I'm working on my funnels or
my landing page or my book or whatever
I'm working on I have a spot on my
calendar for it so I don't stress out I
was like I don't have enough time to do
things yes I do I've designed my life
around it I'm just gonna hit it on
Wednesday I'm not gonna allow
distractions to carry me off course
right it's being willing to let go of
the little balls to go for the big ones
you either you have to pick you're
either constantly taking these little
balls and getting these little wins
answering super promptly on email
responding to everybody right away
taking out these little small bites all
the time
but then never having time to work on
the big project
or you chunk off time to work on your
big projects in life and your business
and that means some of these little
balls are going to drop and that's okay
and you can't judge yourself for losing
some of those because what you're going
to make here is Magic
okay chunking your time setting up the
rails becomes super important and the
last thing I say you have to love the
actual process you want to be happy love
your work how much time do you spend
working a lot right especially if you're
an entrepreneur you spend a lot of time
working love your work the number one
rule for Success from the people that I
profiled from entrepreneurs to athletes
to musicians like you love the actual
thing that you're doing where a lot of
entrepreneurs get caught up is you love
the end result
you love the impact that it can make you
love the idea of buying a house or or
riding a jet plane or whatever the
outcome
but you don't love the path to get there
and if you're just I'll do whatever it
takes you won't you won't do whatever it
takes to get to the outcome and you'll
be stressed out to the max along the way
so rather than doing that flip it to say
I need to love the work that I'm doing
and have it provide economic value to
other people so I can get paid to do it
that's a secret that the outcome is
fantastic it's great awesome hey I got a
million subscribers where's the thing I
got a million subscribers back there
great that's the outcome I love helping
like I love making these videos I love
feeling like this video will matter
means something if you're only chasing
the number you're never going to get
there and you're going to hit your life
in the process good health I firmly
believe comes down to happiness yes diet
exercise all of that but if you are
stressed out if you hate your life if
you despise who you're hanging out with
it's just really hard to be healthy
where if you can now with intention
design a life
where happiness is a priority how many
times have you designed your calendar in
your life around you being happy what a
concept
that happened I guarantee you you're
going to be healthier you're going to
feel
like you're contributing a lot more
you're going to have a lot more energy
you're going to be a better person for
the people around you and you're going
to build a much better business in the
process as well
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to see my
one-on-one interview with Stephen gundry
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there what is one thing
that you believe about energy that most
people don't there's no human need for
fruit just ask an Eskimo if you want
more energy for your workout in the
morning the last